the other victory for the patriots last
night
came from the timing of the leak
of the
cam newton contract
because
i i personally think what was going on
the patriots knew that the nfl was going
to leak and then announce the penalties
from last year's
spygate 3. i don't know how many spy
gates there been it's like rocky movies
last year's incident where
while a camera crew was at a browns
bengals game ostensibly doing a feature
on one of the team scouts
there was recording of the bengals
sideline just a week before the patriots
were due
to play the bengals
now i still have yet to see anything
suggesting that the patriots football
operations staff had anything to do with
this that there were any connections
remember i said from the get-go
investigate this to determine whether or
not there's any connection between these
video crew and football operations and
if you can't prove it then it's just an
innocent mistake and you know what it
may have been a much smaller penalty if
it had been an innocent mistake
that had been committed by anyone else
but these are the patriots and thanks to
spygate1 spygate 2 which never went
anywhere deflategate that history of
violations resulted in the seven figure
fine and the loss of a third round draft
pick it's a big deal to lose a third
round draft pick it's a big deal to lose
any draft pick so
that was significant
but
because it was the chaser to the cam
newton news
it got far less play than it ever would
have gotten making the cam newton move
even more brilliant and making me wonder
at some warped level
whether or not they really don't want
cam newton my mother it was just
elaborate pr cover
for the the long delayed resolution to
something that happened more than six
months ago and i never thought they were
gonna resolve that one but resolve it
they did and you know they did a little
bit of a favor by holding it until after
the 2020 draft by all
respects this should have been done
before the draft that third round pick
2021 we're worth less than a third round
pick in 2020 especially when we consider
that if there's no college football
season or if they delay it or whatever
it's going to be harder potentially to
scout guys next year those draft picks
may not be as value maybe more of a crap
shoot next year than it typically is
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports